bueno es todo esto es parte de un
proceso de una agonía política por el
lado de la de la administración del
issstras tremendamente breve pero
también todo esto se ve como parte de
las consecuencias de decisiones que
fueron tomadas el administración de
Johnson y más todavía hay muchas
críticas que están emergiendo ahora
donde dice todo lo que está ocurriendo
actualmente son coletazos de la decisión
de dejar el anión europea del brexit del
año 2016 entonces hay una serie de
cuestionamientos y hay mucha
incertidumbre porque el partido
conservador no tiene en este momento una
figura Clara de Unión y hay muchas
presiones por parte de la oposición para
llamar a elecciones generales vamos
ahora a hablar de precisamente el
partido conservador que pasa en sus
bases tuvieron la oportunidad de votar
por otra persona en ese momento quien se
jugaba el este liderazgo del partido
conservador con litros que finalmente
fue la ganadora Entonces por qué los
conservadores británicos votaron por
litros cuando no confiaban realmente en
ella digamos que era mejor que regizuma
que igual preferían a listros que a
Richi es una con qué pasó realmente en
esa votación también la van a investigar
No sí hay muchas teorías al respecto ahí
hay algunas interpretaciones que dicen
que hay un tema racial también ahí hay
que tomar en cuenta que muchos de los
miembros del partido conservador las
personas que votaron efectivamente por
listras son alrededor de 150 mil
personas la mayoría blancos mayores de
50 años ingleses que no viven en las
ciudades entonces muchos de ellos
habrían estado muy incómodos y preferían
tener a una primera ministra Blanca esa
es una interpretación hay otra
interpretación que dice que listo a
simplemente le dijo lo que ellos querían
escuchar que era básicamente va a haber
menos impuestos van a bajar y vamos a
tener crecimiento y que muchos de los
planes que ya propuso eran fantasías eso
requiere más análisis pero sí claramente
hubo una una gran equivocación podemos
decir y que afecta no solo el partido
conservador sino que a todo el país y
todo el Reino Unido está en este momento
en crisis porque como estaba diciendo
también no hay en este momento una
figura clara que eh que esté uniendo al
partido conservador qué tiene que pasar
César para que en Reino Unido se
presenten unas elecciones generales me
imagino que pondrán resistencia los del
partido conservador porque pues
evidentemente ante unas elecciones
generales con esta inestabilidad
política podrían ser los vencedores del
partido laborista en su opinión que
puede pasar
hay varios escenarios lo que está claro
es que a corto plazo van a tratar de el
partido conservador va a tratar de
mantener el gobierno
probablemente la situación va a seguir
siendo tremendamente inestable por lo
mismo porque hubo una elección en 2019 y
sería el tercero tercera Primer Ministro
de que proviene desde selección Tendría
que haber por un lado la mayoría del
mismo partido conservador tendría que
votar en contra de un Primer Ministro o
un primer ministra para que este o esta
ya hablará con el Rey Carlos y le dijera
que hay que disolver el parlamento y
Llamar elecciones generales si eso no
ocurre hay que esperar hasta dos años
más hasta el 2024 cuando está
establecido por ley que debería haber
elecciones generales
la espera de dos años en el contexto
actual se ve muy fuerte y muy larga
vamos a tener ahora un nuevo primer o
primera ministra pero
de cuánto va a durar Y eso va a aumentar
la estabilidad del país habiendo dicho
eso al partido laborista por ahora le
conviene esta estabilidad porque todo
esto ha estado ha hecho crecer la
popularidad del partido y todo indica
que según las encuestas actuales
el próximo gobierno Debería ser del
partido labori